there are a few planes in history that
are as admired as the Supermarine
Spitfire and played a pivotal role in
the battle for air supremacy during
World War two its iconic thinman
elliptical wings minimize drag making
this incredibly agile but its German
counterpart the Messerschmitt was a
worthy adversary both planes could reach
speeds of up to 560 kilometers per hour
powered by the huge v12 piston engines
they were remarkably similar planes
featuring low slung wings which
increased their maneuverability a rapid
departure from the biplane era from
which their pilots came both planes
featured retractable landing gears which
many Pollitz were unfamiliar with
causing some to forget to lower their
wheels for landings but the early
versions of this fit fire had an
alarming flaw when performing negative-g
maneuvers the engine would crowd
I believe you can actually see this in
the opening shot of the 1969 movie
Battle of Britain listen for the sound
of the engine cutting out followed by
black smoke a sign of surplus fuel
entering the engine
to understand what is happening here we
need to learn what a carburetor does and
how it works
my carburetors that divides the blends
air and fuel for the internal combustion
engine the carburetor used in the Merlin
engine used a float to control the flow
of fuel into the carburetor tank it's
similar to how your toilet cistern works
the level here is important as it
affects the flow rate into the mixing
chamber a higher level will result in a
higher pressure at the bottom of the
fuel chamber there is a low-pressure
zone created at the nozzle with a
venturi effect which is the reduction in
fluid pressure as it passes through a
constriction this pressure difference
draws fuel from the flow chamber a
larger pressure difference will result
in a richer fuel mixture this air fuel
mixture continues on and enters the
piston cylinder to power the engine the
air fuel makes your percentage can be
altered by opening and closing these two
valves this is the choke off which
closes when starting the engine this
increases the drop in pressure even more
and draws more fuel from the float
chamber resulting in a richer air fuel
mixture which is needed when starting
the engine but an over rich fuel mixture
will not cause an increase in power that
will actually stall the engine remember
this for later the second valve is the
throttle valve which is controlled by
the accelerator and the accelerator is
fully depressed this valve will open to
allow the maximum amount of air and fuel
to enter the engine
this type of carburetor worked flying
would early carries but for a plane that
can turn upside down and enter deep
values it struggles if a plane fitted
with this system under the negative G
dive fuel is forth to the top of the
float chamber this results in the first
loss of power as you can no longer enter
the engine but the float is now forced
down which opens this needle valve
allowing fuel to enter the flow chamber
if this maneuver is held too long the
resulting air fuel mixture will flood
the engine and stall it possibly making
it impossible to start again now that
clip makes a lot more sense as the plane
turns over the engine is starved of fuel
and shuts off then as it returns to
level flight and over rich fuel mixture
enters the engine resulting in the black
smoke German pilots quickly realized
this flaw and it gave them an edge in
dogfights as their planes used a fuel
injection system which didn't suffer
from this problem with the war raging
Britain needed a quick fix for this
problem and this is where Beatriz
Schilling came in Beatrice was a young
female engineer working for the royal
craft establishment she came up with a
beautifully simple stopgap solution for
the problem she installed a simple brass
ring between the end of the fuel intake
pipe and the entrance to the carburetor
chamber this restricted fuel flow into
the carburetor to the maximum that
needed during a dogfight this did not
solve the initial fuel starvation
problem but it did delay the more
serious problem of floating the engine
most importantly it could be installed
quickly at the airfields allowing the
Spitfire pilots to be far more
competitive on from the new pressure
carburetors were installed in 1942
thanks for watching at the start of this
year I wrote down my ambition for the
year and that was to reach a hundred
thousand subscribers and it looks like
I'll be reaching that goal quicker than
I ever expected I want to thank you all
and I want to celebrate with a message
that is important to me
one of the reasons I created this
channel was to highlight some of the
remarkable work engineers do to
transform this world but out of the last
10 videos I've not mentioned a single
female engineer which is reflective of
the actual numbers of women entering the
engineering field and that's a shame I'm
not sure the reasons for this but I
truly believe we need to bring attention
to some of the great female role models
in engineering Beatriz shilling is just
one of them together I hope we can
inspire a new generation of children
that want to use their talents to make
this world a better place if you have a
younger sister or a daughter please
share this video with them unless you
see the impact that can have on the
world thanks again if you want to
support real engineering or see more
content the links from my patreon
Instagram Facebook and Twitter accounts
are below
you